hearthstone has new tavern brawls every
week but for the first time the newest
event will cost money I'm Tony and this
game spot news update isn't free tavern
brawls are usually free but this week's
event will cost you ten dollars or 1,000
gold to enter the heroic brawl as it's
called has some serious rewards for that
financial risk reach 12 wins and you'll
earn 50 packs of cards a big batch of
arcane dust in gold and three golden
legendary cards lose three times and
you're out but you'll get a reward for
your effort no matter how you perform
and the more you win before striking out
the bigger that reward will be of course
losing all three matches upfront won't
win you anything too special this is the
first time a hearth stone tavern brawl
has cost money so we'll see what sort of
precedent this sets for future events in
this case the potential rewards seem
worth the asking price new brawls happen
every week so stick with GameSpot to
stay up-to-date on upcoming events and
for all the biggest hearthstone news
you're already in the right place
you